on accueillons pierre bodein chez lui il
ya quatre mois
j'aurai moi qui n'ignoraient rien de son
passé de braqueur en tant qu'ex color ce
ferrailleur la des paniers par
solidarité ont l'hébergeant dans une
caravane sont jamais soupçonné quoi que
ce soit même après sa première garde à
vue sans arrêt il sans arrêt il parlait
en disant ouais tu te rends compte
moi je suis un braqueur je suis pas un
violeur d'enfant voyez il a il a
tellement ils vous des phases est
complètement
il vous il vous fait il vous faisait
mettre dans la tête qu'il voulait bien
pour vous couvrir lavage de cerveau et
moi le lendemain je laisse encore méfie
pour aller à la piscine et des ramené
après le soit encore dans sa caravane
rejetée par son clan pierre bodein avait
reconstitué le décor de sa cellule il
est pourtant revenu à quelques
kilomètres de bernis le berceau du
bouddha ironie ou prédestination il a
grandi avec ses 15 frères et soeurs rue
de la justice aujourd'hui à sa simple
évocation les portes se ferment
mais ce que vous pensez qu'il a pu faire
ça non je les pense pas j'ai des 10 déjà
et puis c'est fini et laissez nous
tranquilles car depuis son traumatisme
crânien et ses trois mois de coma pierre
bodein est infréquentable
pierrot le fou comme on l'appelle alors
fait plusieurs séjours en établissement
psychiatrique
ici pendant trois ans il a simulé le
fait d'être grabataire
cette expertise psychiatrique parmi
d'autres confluent un sujet dangereux
atteint d'une psychose schizophrénique
c'est sans doute quelqu'un qui est un
handicap et au départ qui a des
problèmes psychologiques graves qui à
partir de là peut-être parce qu' il ne
peut pas en parler peut être dans des
passages à l'acte pour la justice pierre
bodein était un multirécidiviste pas un
délinquant sexuel